Nikki: You're looking
at the Magic Wand.
It's smooth, sleek,
and powerful,
just like my friend
comedian Sara Schaefer.
Today, we handed off
the controls
of these bad boys
and sat on them.
Buckle up, bitches.
This is "Comedians Sitting
on Vibrators Getting Coffee."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Before we go any further,
would you like to have,
like, a safe word?
My safe word is
"Theon Greyjoy."
-[ Chuckles ]
-That means winter is coming.
I'll just be laugh--
Oh, my God!
You really are, like,
getting possessed by a demon.
You were one
of the first people
I ever heard talk
about squirting.
I don't like that term
'cause it sounds gross to me,
but I prefer other terms.
Like, you can call me
"Splash Mountain"!
[ Laughs ]
But I have to tell you
how I --
how I discovered
that I could do it.
Okay.
I was -- I was --
No, Theon Greyjoy.
Theon Greyjoy.
[ Laughs ]
Have some decency.
It was like a water balloon
popped between my legs.
Are [Bleep]-ing right now,
or are you shocked by the story?
-No, I'm shocked by the story.
-Okay.
'Cause you were like...
[ Laughs ]
I'm on the edge
of my clit.
I was really embarrassed
by it at first, you know,
and if a guy
did have a problem with it,
I'd be like,
"Get out of here!"
[ Both laugh ]
Is it actually squirting,
or is it more --
-It's a gush.
-So it should be gushing.
I like waterfall.
Water is falling.
Don't go chasin'.
-Like, right now.
So, what is the amount of --
of -- of -- ooooof...
How much liquid
could I expect?
Have you ever had
a Capri Sun?
Of course.
It's like two of those.
Two of those?!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
[ Laughs ]
This is the best coffee
I've ever had.
Yeah, me, too.
This is really great.
-Geez!
-We should do this more often.
Mnh-mnh, mnh-mnh,
mmm!
Theon Greyjoy!
[ Laughs ]
-Did I get you? I'm sorry.
-No, no, no.
-Normally, they like that.
-I'm already wet.
[ Both laugh ]